hey guys I'm Craig I'm John I am
incredibly sick I am like getting hot
and cold sweats this ear is like totally
clogged up I can't hear out of it I got
a sore throat I'm sorry I got a lot a
lot more too but [ __ ] it
Suicide Squad trailer - it's out and
subscribers don't care if you're sick
they just want you to watch it anyway so
Jay are you ready I'm so ready and I
feel like I've already seen I like how
it says it's a Ben Affleck Margot Robbie
movie from movieclipstrailers nothing
like give it away that Ben Affleck
Sanders even more gentlemen ladies what
if Superman I decided to fly down rip
off the roof of the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office
everybody good debate in BBS who would
have stopped him hopefully
oh [ __ ]
I want to build a team of some very bad
people who I think can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy
Thanks nice what are you Ravi
this is the deal you just pay me you die
try to escape you die
no boyfriend you irritate or vex me I'm
known to be quite vexing I'm just for
warning you you duck they get caught we
throw them under the bus let's boy mutt
get something better
I love this guy
that good yes good for the bad guys are
you sweet-talking me how are that
chit-chats gonna get charged oh [ __ ]
wash the crock
but you can do you wanna see some oh
yeah one who is this dog yes I want to
see stop I was just trying to get you
there no hard feelings right we good
what you having weird whisky what am i
12 how are you have stuff water that's a
good idea huh
fire it's what made it fun Oh again did
I thought he had a crippling addiction
hands are trying to keep away from you
no I don't really have much different
opinion than the last trail I mean it
just solidifies like yeah it still looks
cool still looks fun but my worry though
is this there's nothing out so they're
doing the reshoots for Suicide Squad to
make it more fun and then the last
trailer for Suicide Squad look like a
really fun movie and then they make this
announcement saying um we didn't make it
more fun well and I couldn't tell what
was speculation to what was extent say
like oh we put all the jokes in the
trailer or did they just go we just need
to make it funnier they said they said
that they just need to make it funnier
and you know it's like this trailer was
a lot of fun but I'm like is this from
the original cut or is there some new
footage in here that the reshooting
to make it more fun if it is this tone
that they're actually aiming to work
that would be cool that would be really
cool there'd be a lot better than some
super serious film I'm hoping that with
the reshoots at least cuz the reshoot
thing kind of got me a little worried
then reshoot stuff a lot I'm worried
because of the decisions but they never
make an announcement saying yeah they
never kind of serious so we need to make
it more funny they never do that thing
where they're like hey [ __ ] you for
thinking our other movies bad but hey
we're gonna try and make this other one
oh yeah exactly
the trailers both look really cool to me
and this one was the same for me too
it's like it kind of gives us a better
sense for the setup but mostly it just
tells us what we already know which is
here the Suicide Squad - here's some fun
music while they function and we don't
exactly know what their mission is yet
which I like cuz we're seeing a lot of
footage from Suicide Squad but we're
still like what's the exact plot yeah
all I know is they come together and
they got
work with that guy from the killing and
what's the Joker's involvement in this
you know yeah like part of the Susan I
think he is obviously uh but actually
that's what I think is cool is the way
they're building up the joke or even
these trailers like that he's always
somewhere the shadows or he's always big
hinted at and he looks like some of
those quick shots look terrifying and
he's build a second yeah you know right
right behind Will Smith I don't know if
that's just because of stardom or not or
just how huge the character the job
exactly exactly it might be because the
character is so hugely involved it and
it's nice to see that they're like not
trying to make it about the Joker when
they advertise that because a lot of us
are gonna tune in just to see what the
chokers like well that's just funny to
me unless they you know really blow a
whole bunch of stuff in another trailer
like it's always weird to think that
these are coming for the same people cuz
this is like I think that what they're
doing with these trailers is working
like yeah they're hinting at the right
stuff and just like you said we don't
really know what the actual mission is I
want to see the movie to find this [ __ ]
out yeah exactly cuz you know like a big
complaint of the marketing for BBS was
the fact that they reveal too much yeah
and I don't feel like they reveal too
much here no I feel like we were getting
just enough I feel like we're getting a
good tease and all the characters
personality it looks like a good
ensemble piece you know it looks like
team mid-tones
yeah that's aggregating it looks like a
hood in Samba movie where like in like
Will Smith's charm we actually seen this
trailer yeah for his large is really
serious Will Smith we're some kind of
Suicide Squad he's like the guy who's
like funny cuz he's no [ __ ] yeah but
now it's like okay we got the fun Will
Smith in here too and Margot Robbie
looks like she's doing a great job as an
incredible body a lover I would think
about her sometimes guy Courtney my
courts looks like he's I might you know
this is my like every time I like him
that this might be after 10 or 11 50 I'm
sweating so much oh my god oh so sick
goes on oh oh shut up yeah sorry I'm
Moody like El Diablo looks pretty cool I
like how a little Smith and I were
having that back and forth kind of share
that Will Smith is kind of the leader of
the Suicide Squad in a way yeah you know
like sure you know seeing Deadshot do
that is pretty cool but I'm glad he's
gonna have a personality beyond that
skull tattoo loves it and Killer Croc I
want to see what kind of personality
they bring for him by strong
interpretation of Killer Croc
actually comes from the Batman animated
series where he is like a thuggish
and shit-talking [ __ ] who's just
a brutal force he's nasty and I don't
feel like we really got a strong sense
of what the Killer Croc is your other
than he looks
healing looks good it looks good and is
that like that looks like an awesome
practical effect to its effect achill I
couldn't tell when it was practical and
CGI I mean I'm sure it's enhanced but a
lot of it looked like you know like a
really nice silicone mask or something
like that linked Etana looks pretty cool
too you know seeing her wield that sword
and [ __ ] yeah they showed some Batman
footage in there which is like all right
whatever I mean yes their clothes I hope
that's their max of showing us something
new that's my jumps into water and he
flies through a shadow like that's all
we need to know he almost had as much
screen time with this trailer is the
Joker did yeah I mean there's a part in
the trailer where you hear the Joker
laughing and then Harley Quinn's like
uh-oh and Deadshot's like not good that
moment I don't know if they're just
slicing audio of the Joker and throwing
it in there man look like they're
reacting to that but I would have
expected a different response from
Harley Quinn in that moment yeah cuz you
know she's essentially created by the
Joker so unless they've been estranged
for a while maybe they're going for a
less you know nasty release yeah
treatment it looks like it's gonna be a
cool moving I'm sure it's gonna deliver
a lot of stuff that we want and I mean
the big talk I jet is gonna be better
than BBS I don't think you need to
compare them I'm not it's not a big bar
to click but I think I I think in the
end even though I've only seen the
trailers it's not BBS twice and even
though I've only seen two trailers for
Suicide Squad something tells me that I
will have a preference for Suicide Squad
in the end like we had we had issues the
BBS trailers and and thus far even if as
was the house shaky it is with them
doing reshoots it up the two trailers
I've seen inspire confidence
yeah it's theirs to lose at this point
and it's like the kinds of scenes we get
from this like I get a sense for the
movie where's BBS every trailer felt
like a different movie mm-hmm so like I
don't know I think they got enough to
work with so hopefully they don't [ __ ]
it up all right guys well thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
hooks subscribe today
come reject and reject John's playlist
on this channel there's a
here describing what they're called and
I'm I don't know like it's like I want
to sleep but then I go to sleep I start
getting cold and I start sweating and I
can't function I'm just you know what
the thing is I feel really sorry for
myself right now like I pity myself yeah
you know and I hear self-pity is one of
the most attractive qualities a man can
have so yeah I just feel really bad for
me and I'm hoping that victim role
causes girls to be like I gotta make him
feel happier because of how good-looking
he is yeah yeah yeah because you're
attracting them with your self-pity
you're showing them to your person to be
pitied they should pity you as well part
of the Act people it's all part of the
game